well in an abrupt reversal House leaders
announcing lawmakers will not return to
Washington next week as expected that
move leaving the status of new stimulus
for millions of out-of-work Americans
who are hurting badly economically up in
the air we have no choice if this the
Capitol physician says that recommends
that we not come back then we have to
take that guidance and the interest of
the safety of the people who work here
the custodians in the building that
those who have to be here
let's bring in Ohio congressman and
ranking member of the House Oversight
Committee Jim Jordan congressman always
good to see you thanks for being here to
be with you
you bet all right so do you do you agree
with that decision and we kind of all
remember the image last week of you
showing up for the stimulus vote no mask
made a few headlines for that so do you
think that the threat was still enough
to keep members of Congress from
returning to Washington Sandra states
are reopening why won't Congress I mean
look
farmers are planting crops truckers are
moving goods groceries are stocking
shelves and frontline health care
workers have never stopped where they've
been working every single day throughout
this crisis but somehow the US Congress
can't come back to work I mean we got
task force meeting in the White House
task but I'm on one of these tasks task
force meeting all over the country but
the task force that's supposed to meet
and deal with big issues that confront
our nation is the United States Congress
so let's get back in session and in fact
we did that last week I testified in the
hearing you're describing so we can do
it I don't know why we're not back doing
the work of the American people it seems
like that's exactly where we should be
but unfortunately Nancy Pelosi won't
call us back all right we will take that
as you disagree with that decision to
not return to DC so congressman as far
as this fourth strongly this fourth
round of stimulus this is largely being
debated now the questions over whether
or not there will be bipartisan support
for another relief package where do you
stand well the best stimulus is to go
back to work
the best phase for is to go back to work
and we're seeing states do that so I
mean look we've already spent three
trillion dollars and and that was
necessary because when when
local government state governments tell
business owners you can't you can't
engage in your livelihood you can't run
your business you have to deal with that
you have to help families and have to
help small business owners but the best
proach now is let's simply go back to
work and we're seeing states begin to do
that our state's beginning to do that
let's do that as quickly as possible
that's the best stimulus that's the best
bailout that's the best phase for go
back to work so we'll see what what what
may happen as we go but I hope we can
just get back to work and get our
economy up and running again